hello and welcome to this video playing
sv mihaylov Oh got 10 out of 11 against
him a time two draws nine wins he never
beat me very very likely i'm lucky
against him and for that kind of score
you you need to be need to be lucky okay
I'm we rooting the bishop to d6 and
trying to ultimately get something on
there on the King side okay he's
shooting form b form why did I take the
actually keeping the tension is quite
interesting and I applied that to
quickly of it should if I should have
kept the tension after the dark squared
Bishop SAR traded this is an interesting
option against the against the minority
attack okay it's not a big deal but
still I should have thought about this
the a bishop takes h3 as mine easy to
see threat but he doesn't have a
completely easy reply to that there
should be two there's Bishop to f5 so
that's not helping that much 92a have
queen age for me angling for the
sacrifice hmm not quite sure what you
should do you just went back okay
okay what is he up to 2 c1 show hmm ok I
mean I want to be ready to answer b5
with with c5 let's split splits good
let's protect d5 them right on h2o sir
not that great anyway now is going back
interesting so maybe here so be five
there is c5
ok let's try to do something on the a
file yeah I got the a file for some
reason and now see what happens again be
fine there is c5 and that doesn't net
white that much I believe hmm yeah
Teague or not to take I think I'll go
back attacking before
yeah I know c5 right
yeah that shouldn't be bad for black
kind of equal ish I believe even though
in this particular version I mean the
structures pretty commonplace and in
Queens Queens gambit declined strayer
exchanges but here in comparison to
other forms I've got a pretty active
route and the knight on c3 is loose hmm
interesting my bishop on c5 I don't know
if that is an ideal player p.m. I think
I'll go back my ideas to play so h5
maybe and then Bishop to e 50 at the
move I didn't think of it all
hmm just seem to seems to trade stuff
hmm
ok if you takes I'm taking with the pawn
I always going back ok interesting
check night c forum for possible night
to D to the Queen has no squares so
let's take and again I'm I'm threatening
to drive the Queen here yeah which she
will probably prevent somehow even even
by accident he probably prevent it and
ok anyway so what to do see doing see
attacking something I don't see it like
this is not hanging maybe look on the
second look on the second rank
not sure that this threatens anything
with okay so he says he is threatening
something something even though if I
just take it Queen takes Queen f7 there
is an issue there with the background
check he has a background problem and
the night is hanging this is an
additional problem so there's more than
one hole I believe in his concept here
Queen takes with the group textbook a
one is made plus the night is hanging so
it really doesn't work at all yeah
that's at least my take on it I don't
see how him it's not using huge amounts
of material now yeah maybe if you gave
it the light is hanging so if he moves
the Queen away I'll just take the night
so yeah I can shape the light also
threatening retakes f2 with mate so on
you just falls apart completely white
resigns hmm yeah it was a I think I had
a decent position there was not much
happening and then it kinda went went
downhill rather quickly I made 11
mistake I am well mistake is strong but
and I don't need to take now on before I
mean this is not bad to take but it's
interesting in this kind of situation
where there is no dark squared Bishop
anymore
my membership is on that diagonal to
just keep the tension and play a move
like this because after b5 this is
hanging and this can become interesting
in this particular case it's not good to
take because he has this move attacking
here and here but having this general
they say this possibility to just not
take it or can be interesting yeah okay
but this is what's the normal way to
play it he I'm threatening it with this
capture and now he went back interesting
the engine wants to play Knights you
form that to move I didn't consider but
why is that good so the engine sacrifice
upon and now wants to do this move
because of this idea and say look here
and then look a 3 and this kind of play
is difficult for a human player the
engine gives me a clear advantage
probably because I'm technically
regaining material and it's two bishops
against two nights which is very often
where the porn but now that's not
something that I can play in a blitz
game not sure about a long time control
game but in a blitz can I don't know
yeah well I was content with just kind
of keeping keeping an edge with the
bishop and somewhat easier to play
position and here Oh Bishop before
already was strong very strong I don't
get the point I because of his hanging
loops yeah that would have one became
actually I take this and if it nine
moves t3 is hanging so we should be for
was rather easy and here h five wins she
did not play why does that win I don't
quite get it if he goes back i takes to
experience e7 check a very bad tactic
play me I can take and here I'm Jack and
I'm winning this stuff I just kept Jack
kept attention in winter yeah and this
better for me but not winning and then
he blundered with night f5 and check to
which I'm tons of material up he had to
play Queen to do one this is what the
engine is giving Queen f7 and here black
us more active but this is far from
being a winning position it's just
comfortable and and okay but it's not a
win in the next couple of moves by any
stretch of the imagination so he could
have defended this much much better okay
well thanks for watching